la crisis de seguridad hace saltar todas
las alarmas en mozambique la
organización human right watch ha pedido
a la comunidad internacional que redoble
sus esfuerzos para combatir la
insurgencia islámica en el país después
de la toma de la ciudad norteña de palma
por militares de harlistas
es hora de que la comunidad de
desarrollo del sur de áfrica trate este
asunto como una prioridad y de que las
autoridades de mozambique digan al mundo
lo que está ocurriendo y la ayuda que
necesitan en el asalto a palma fue el
último de una serie de ataques en la
región de cabo delgado rica en gas la
provincia posee varios yacimientos de
carbón y gas así como importantes
reservas de petróleo en alta mar también
es una de las dos regiones donde la
mayoría de la población es musulmana en
una nación tradicionalmente cristiana en
la última década varias multinacionales
extranjeras como total y exxonmobil han
invertido masivamente en la explotación
de los recursos de cabo delgado
incluyendo un proyecto de 20 mil
millones de dólares para extraer gas
natural licuado conocido como la planta
gene l pero estos proyectos se han
convertido en blancos para las milicias
yihadistas
que lanzaron una insurgencia en 2017 en
impulsada por las privaciones religiosas
así como la pobreza y las desigualdades
generalizadas el grupo rebelde al shabab
lanzó una serie de ataques brutales
contra objetivos gubernamentales y
civiles en la ciudad en 2019 los
islamistas prometieron lealtad al grupo
estado islámico y en 2020 lograron
capturar en dos ocasiones la estratégica
ciudad portuaria norteña de mushing boat
a praia a pesar de hacer de la seguridad
su máxima prioridad y de contar con la
ayuda de potencias extranjeras y
mercenarios el gobierno mozambiqueño
tiene dificultades para hacer frente a
la insurgencia unas 2.600 personas han
muerto por los ataques desde 2017 y
otras 700 mil se han visto obligadas a
huir de sus hogares según naciones
unidas